were one of the top one or two
manufacturers in the world we have seven
brands as a group and the small ones
that we build is 27 feet the largest
vote that we build is 80 meters we have
a space here all undercover and what
we've tried to do here is really create
an automotive retail type environment
for the marine industry we have this
space here we use is a lounge space they
can go and they can relax they can look
at the product you've got a quick way
effect so any one time we have upwards
of really thirty million dollars of
inventory
we bought the distribution in the
America and so we sell directly so if
you walk into a store and full-auto
though it's branded through this you're
buying from the factory I spend a
tremendous amount of my time with
clients in front of clients and I hear
what they like I or they don't like and
because I work for the manufacturer we
have a system here where we feed that
information back like wigs and Factory
when we have them at a point where we've
discussed the bow we've narrowed it down
they've identified the product that they
want to buy we take them out and enjoy
the experience in the American market
what we found is that the buyers are
quite impossible it's surprising how
quickly people will make a decision some
people are looking for an instant
gratification they're looking to walk in
they see something they like it no Buy
you